one of the most compelling and i don't
know entertaining and
fascinating exploration world war one
comes from dan carlin i don't know if
you've gotten a chance to
listen to his sort of
podcast form telling of the blueprint
for our armageddon which is the telling
of world war one what do you think about
dan carlin are you yourself as a
historian who has studied who's written
about world war one do you
do you enjoy that kind of telling of
history
absolutely and i think uh again you know
uh you don't need a phd in history to to
be a historian right um does every
historian agree with that he gets quite
a bit of criticism from historians uh
you know i mean
we you know we like to argue with each
other and nitpick with each other but um
but the one thing i have no patience for
is when we like pull rank on each other
um you know i think
um we depend on uh
you know if you're you know a historian
in a university with degrees and
research materials you know you depend
on the work of people
in some local community like recording
oral histories saving documents
and
history is a it's a social science but
it's also a storytelling art
and
you know
history books are the ones you find on
the shelves and bookstores that people
read for for fun and and then and you
can appreciate both the the knowledge
production um as well as the
storytelling um and when you get a good
oral storyteller like dan carlin um
there's a reason that
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
people tune in
yeah but he definitely suffers from
anxiety about getting things corrected
it's very it's very difficult
well our first job is to get the facts
the facts correct and then and then to
tell the story off of those
because the the facts are so fuzzy so
it's uh
i mean you have the
probably my favorite telling of world
war ii
is
william shires rise and fall the third
reich
and uh or at least not telling of nazi
germany and that
goes to primary sources a lot
which is
like
i suppose that's the honest way to do it
but it's tough it's really tough to
write that way to really go to primary
sources
always and i think the one of the things
that dan tries to do
which is also really tough to do perhaps
easier in oral history is uh
try to make you feel what it was like to
be there
which i i think he does by trying to
tell the story of like individual
soldiers and
um
[Music]
do you find that telling
like individual citizens do you find
that kind of telling of history
compelling
yeah i mean i think we need a
historical imagination
and i think
historical imagination teaches something
very valuable which is humility
to realize that
there are
other people um who've lived on this
planet and they organized their lives
differently and
you know they made it through just fine
too um and
um
you know i think that that uh that kind
of of
of meeting other people from the past
can be actually a very useful skill for
meeting people unlike you in the present
unlike you but also like you i think
both are uh both are humbling one
realizing that they did lived in a
different space and time
but two realizing that if you if you
were placed in that space and time you
might have done
all the same things whether it's the
brave good thing or the evil thing
yeah absolutely
and you get a also a sense of um
uh of possibility you know there's this
famous line right that um you know those
who do not learn history are condemned
to repeat it
but i think the other half is true as
well which is those who do not learn
history don't get the chance to repeat
it
right you know that we're not the first
people on this planet to face you know
any certain kinds of problems um you
know other people have have lived
through worlds like this one before
it's like when you fall in love as a
teenager for the first time there's and
then there's a breakup
you think it it's the greatest strategy
tragedy that has ever happened in the
world you're the first person
even though like
romeo and juliet and so on had had this
issue you're the first person that truly
feels the catastrophic
heartbreak of that experience
it's good to be reminded that no
the human condition is what it is we
have lived through it at the individual
in the societal scale
you